This is the motivation for a memory
consistency model, which is called release consistency. I'm
sure just from the keyword release some of you may have already formed a mental
model of what I'm going to say. Basically,
we're going to look at the structure of the
program As follows that the Peddler program
consists of several different Peddler threads P1 is
one such, and if it wants to mess with
some shared data structures, it is going to acquire
a lock, we'll call it A1, and in the
mind of the programmer there is an association between this
lock and the data structures governed by it. So,
so long as they hold the lock, they can
modify the data structure and r1 is the release
of this lock. So every critical section you can think
of as composed of and acquire followed by data accesses governed
by the lock and then release. If the same lock is used
by some other process at P2, and if the critical section
of P1 preceded the critical section of P2 or in other
words, P1's release operation P1, r1. The release
operation and P1 happened before, this most be familiar to you from our
discussion of Lampert's logical clock. P1 R1 happens before P2 R2, that
is the acquire operation that is being done by P2 if this acquire operation
for the same lock happened after the release by P1 R1.
All we have to ensure is that all the coherence
actions prior to this release of the lock by P1
has to be complete before we allow P2 to
acquire this lock before we allow P2 to acquire the same lock
L. That's the idea of release consistency. So we take the synchronization
operations that are provided by the system
whether it is hardware or software And
we label them as either an acquired operation or a release operation. So, it's
very straight forward when you think about
mutual explosion law, acquiring the log primitive
is an acquire operation. And the un log primitive is a release operation. So if
there is a lock primitive and there is
a PCD unlock primitive, so we have to ensure
that all the coherence actions happen before I
do the unlock so that when this guy gets
the lock and accesses the data, the data that he is going to see are going to
be data that is consistent with whatever modifications may
have been made over here. That's the idea behind
the least consistent memory operation. Other synchronization operations
can also be mapped to acquiring release. If
you think about barrier, arriving at a barrier
is equivalent to an acquire, and leaving the
barrier is equivalent to a release. So, before
leaving the barrier, we have to make sure
that any changes that we made to shared
data structures is reflected through all the other processes
through the cache coherence mechanism. Then we can leave
the barrier. So, leaving the barrier is a release
operation, in the case of barrier synchronization. So, what
that means is that, if I do a shared
memory access within this group of sections, and that
shared memory access would normally result in some coherence
actions on the interconnect reaching to the other processes
and so on, and if we use the SC
memory model, you will block processes if you
want until That particular memory access is complete
with respect to all the processors and the
shared memory machine. But if we use the least
consistent memory model, we do not have to
block P1 in order for coherence actions to be
complete to let the processor continue on with
its computation. We only have to block a processor
at a release point to make sure that
any coherent actions that may have been initiated
up until this point, are all complete before
we perform this release operation. That's the key
point that I want you to get out of this release consistent memory model. So the
least consistent memory model allows exploitation of computation
on P1, with communication that may be happening through
the coherence mechanism for completing the coherence actions corresponding to
the memory accesses that you're making inside the critical section.